hey what's up guys welcome back to our
channel my name's samuel and i'm amanda
and this is the samuel and amanda show
where we talk about money
marriage and life and in this week's
episode what are we going to be what's
the theme
today going to be the theme of today is
going to be generous
giving and um it's going to be all about
charity
and our charity works and we're going to
be talking about i think the
the other side so not just the um like
what we do but also maybe like the bad
things sometimes that can come with
people when they you know decide to give
yeah so basically generous giving but
also intelligent giving
because sometimes when you try and you
can try and give you can try and be
helpful and it can actually backfire so
we're going to talk about it
yeah and not just not just small
charities but also really big charities
you know we've seen many times when
going about you know how to work
who we're going to give to you how we're
going to help our village and uh and
we've seen other charities and
organizations and they're giving us kind
of also almost
um they've gone out with good intentions
but it's it's actually backfired so
we're gonna be talking about some of the
problems
when setting up a charity or when giving
whether it's just giving 20 pounds or
whether it's giving 2 million pounds
but first what have you been up to this
week
this week um okay so the last couple of
weeks this week it's been quite hard
really because
my granddad's been unwell and he's in
zimbabwe
and he's my only surviving granddad um
on my dad's side
so it's just been a little bit tough
he's had to he had a fall and he
fractured his hip
and he had to have a hip replacement and
stuff so that's been really tough
because obviously
we haven't been able to go out to see
him and
we know we always go out to zimbabwe
like at least once a year but
because of covid and everything it's
just been really difficult so
i think that's been a bit tough but he
did have a successful surgery so
i'm really glad about that and um yeah
we're just praying for him so
yeah how old is big security 89
yeah in zimbabwe 89 and we've been
as well even without him having this
fall we've been itching to go out i know
about kids i mean we've had
um i mean we've got a lockdown baby
jessica and luke
was he's not a lockdown baby but the he
was 2019.
so we haven't you know i don't he's not
even met luke yet so yeah
it is crazy so we're kind of just
praying that he stays healthy
praying that the flights open up so we
can go back
um but yeah that that's been uh it's
been difficult but
god is in control and we're just gonna
keep praying that he
recovers well which he is um anything
else what you've been we've been
cracking lacking with
just besides praying for your just life
admin really boring stuff but just
catching up on lots of
stuff a lot of red tape my end planning
planning permissions
um close to going through and just
waiting on the councils
also yesterday i spent the full day with
ricky mandel who's awesome
helping him he's been done very well
very very successful in property
and now i'm helping him with his mission
you know it's
setting up his whether it enterprises
charities or helping him with his
speaking communication
so it's really good spending a full day
with him um so if you've got any
questions for myself or amanda
anything that you want to ask us we
often in our podcasts we do
respond to comments on youtube so if
you're on youtube great if you're not on
youtube get to the youtube version
start commenting below so okay giving
charities so little tiny bit of
background and then i want you to talk
about maybe some of the
things that you can do the things that
um
you can donate to which might not be a
good thing but i mean
how the charity the samuel lisa
foundation was set up was oh i didn't
want to be a full-time fundraiser i saw
a lot of people in my church
that set out because they wanted to help
people but then actually they spent
their entire time going around
with begging bowls saying can you donate
can you donate and i believe that you
can't help the poor by being poor
yourself
so that's why i set up my business
initially my property business
which took off really well and as a
result we have an obligation a duty a
responsibility
to give to help others if you are
generous sorry if you are
wealthy you have a responsibility to be
generous so
but as well as being generous you've
also got to be intelligent
with your generosity so why don't you
give an example as someone who's born
and bred
in zimbabwe in harare yeah what have you
seen some of the um especially from
folks from america
you know white organizations that don't
understand the culture don't understand
the the background the politics that
just just give
generously give me an example of
something wrong i think an example or
something like that is like
for example if someone comes from abroad
and then they come in and then they just
see all these kids orphans or whatever
and then they take
them out of their community away from
their friends and their family that they
have
oh yeah and then and then they build an
orphanage which is great
you know it seems like a great idea but
then what actually happens is that then
they're sheltered in there until they're
like 16 years old
and then at 16 it's kind of like okay
we've looked after you now
you've grown up you can go off into the
world and actually i think
because they've been away from i guess
the real world or whatever and then also
as well they haven't been prepared
or you know for going out into the world
and then you know getting a job or
moving on to i don't know education or
whatever then i think
it can have the opposite effect to maybe
what they would have wanted
and taking taking kids off of their
parents like
yeah and their parents might at the time
might even willingly let them because
they think oh they're gonna have a
better life and a better education
but as you say it it looks great oh we
just built an orphanage for these for
these children and
but actually um yeah you've got to be
really careful because as you say you
can shelter them and then when they're
16 then what
yeah so i think i think a lot what
happens with charities is that
they don't often teach you how to fish
so they don't teach the kids how to
they don't give them the skills they
sort of just take them do everything for
it for them
but then don't actually teach them like
this is how you survive yeah so i think
that's what can happen and then you know
it's not
good yeah absolutely another thing as
well on business because obviously i'm
very business-minded and some of the
things that i've seen happen
um is there's parts of africa where
there's
mosquito problems and you know if if you
get
um bitten by a mosquito and you can get
ill you can die
and one of the things that happened some
years ago was a bunch of americans
went over to an area which was you know
mosquito ridden
and just dumped thousands and thousands
of mosquito nets
um for the children and for people to
have here you go woof and they just gave
them all these mosquito nets
and then left went back to america and
that was that now you might think that's
a great thing now suddenly all these
kids they've all got these mosquito nets
it means they can be protected from the
mosquitoes
and whilst it kind of was a good thing
um
the the devastating long effect was that
there was a lot of um villagers who
small businesses who had mosquito nets
they they sold mosquito nets that was
their business
and when these americans came over and
just said he go woof
and just gave tens of thousands of
mosquito nets then
all of the locals stopped buying
mosquito nets
and the mosquito net businesses went out
of business
so oh so suddenly the the the the
the shops who were set up and used to
sell mosquito nets so they're like oh
well
we're out of business now so they went
out of business now you might say well
so they went out of business so what but
now these people aren't gonna get
mosquito bitten but what happened was
mosquito nets don't last that long
so after a year or two all of these
mosquito nets
have now got rips and you know warning
wear and tear
but now the people that sell mosquito
nets have gone buzzed as well
so suddenly you've got a massive problem
on your hands
good intention sounds great oh i'll just
dump a load of mosquito nets but
actually
you know not thinking intelligently not
thinking about the long-term
effects of what's going to happen when
you make that when you make that move
wow that's awful yeah that's right so
that's kind of you need to be careful of
um
another thing as well that i have a
slight not issue with and i get it it's
fine
but and it sounds like we're kind of
just saying you know bashing what people
have done and that's not the case
at all what what we're saying is just
do it carefully just think before before
you go and give a lot of money and even
that's
even the case isn't it if not just
africa or overseas even
in the uk if you're given to a homeless
person we all know that
if you give 50 pounds to a homeless
person there's a reasonable chance
that the money is not going to be spent
on on food or whatever they might spend
it on drugs
um i mean ultimately i think god judges
the heart when you give in
but you might think a little bit more
intelligently like i know when you give
to homeless people you usually
buy them a meal or instead of giving
cash yeah so it's
tricky it's not straightforward but what
do you what do you think
yeah i think that like you said god
touches the heart so sometimes
you know you may feel like actually i
don't want to just i mean i feel like
sometimes
i don't want to just buy them a sandwich
i feel like i need to give them some
money
and you know what they do with that then
it's like okay it's out of my hands but
when i gave that money for me it's like
i came from a good place and yeah you
know
it's where i'm coming from so i think
i think i think it's really important to
come from a good place if you're coming
from a good place though
normally if you're coming from a good
place when you give in you will
investigate a little bit about the best
ways to give you'll think you'll talk
with the community you'll talk with the
chiefs
we always partner with either the chief
or the or the government
and figure out exactly um i think one of
the problems is not coming from a good
place it's just going oh
let's just put 20 grand into this thing
wanting to be the hero wanting to be a
hero
yeah not actually thinking about what
you're doing just wanting to look big
and feel
big yeah saying i donated this but not
actually again again doing the
investigation doing the research
to know what the needs are of that
community not taking the time
yeah not taking the time and that's
really important that you take the time
out
to really speak to the right people yeah
um
even charities if you're given to
charity often you're given to a charity
and that charity is
you know give it paying their ceo half a
million pound salary a year and
the actually the money and one of the
problems that i have as well while i'm
on this rant
is i get really upset i get really upset
about
um and some of the guys here listening
to me will probably get upset with me
for saying this
but all i'll say is just go and research
don't take what i'm saying as gospel and
just oh samuel said it
just have your mind open to do your
research but when i see these
uh like red nose day and things like
that i get a little bit upset because
not necessarily just where the money's
going because often when you give to big
charities they give the money to the
government
the african government and then they
then spend it on themselves and it
doesn't really
distribute the people but the main
problem that i have is the way
and we're so careful about this amanda
when i say what i'm about to say
because the way that what they'll do is
they'll like take pictures and videos of
um you know kids starving you know real
real problem things but then plaster it
all over the uk
tv and people will have sympathy and
everything like that
yeah and whilst that might be true and
the kids are starving yes they are it's
a problem
the thing that we don't love is the way
that almost i don't know how how would
you work i feel like it's really
annoying because
when you think if i say oh africa i
think automatically a lot of people
automatically just
have this vision of like oh really bad
place oh
yeah poverty and it's just like it
almost makes you not really
want to go there because you think is it
really that great it's not really like
oh holiday destination
yeah which it actually is which actually
is such a beautiful
continent and zimbabwe is a beautiful
country yeah you know
and it's it's actually weird because for
example america
when we went when you see america it's
just like oh the land of dreams it's
amazing
when we went to america we were really
surprised at the homelessness that we
saw
california it was ridiculous literally
i've
never
seen yeah i mean i've never seen it that
like that bad anywhere homeless people
it was
everywhere yeah riddled with crime
shocking terrible
but but but but the thing is with the
americans is they're good marketers yeah
yeah so the americans know how to market
themselves and as a country everyone
wants to go to america everyone wants to
visit everyone wants to do business with
the americans
because of how they market themselves
even when you watch the tv if it's an
american show
they'll only show the best yeah you'll
be like does an average person really
live in houses like this
but it's like wolf the land of dreams as
you say
whereas i feel like with with um africa
you know most of africa people just
think
poverty and one of the reasons is
because of what the western countries
have done
with showing you know off this and
they'll find the worst
parts yeah and they'll portray us and i
do think that's a problem i think it
makes people not want it it ruins
tourism
it makes countries not want to do
business with with
africa generally as a continent yeah and
we're really careful about that aren't
we because of course we give and we do
see
we see people that are very very very
poor um
but very rarely do we plaster it across
social media
um and and and film it it doesn't feel
humane no
it doesn't you know we want to empower
the people that we're helping
not make them feel less than or you know
it's just yeah i don't really like
degrading
and humane to film somebody suffering
and then plaster it on youtube
yeah and stuff so we want to empower we
run business workshops we give
little business loans out and they go
and then sell businesses
train them teach them yes we bring food
and water and and shelter
uh doing schools and things like that
and i'm not saying that we've never
taken pictures of anything that we're
doing but we are very careful aren't we
not yeah
um not not to um change the perception
of of these countries as a whole yeah um
so okay
cool so moral of the stories is to give
generously yeah to also give
intelligently
um what advice would you give to
somebody amanda
talk a little bit about how who to
partner with like when we go out what we
do
so when we go out we usually have a
contact um who we then have as like
our guide in the country but i think you
have to be careful because sometimes
even the guide
i mean they have their own agenda
everyone has their own agenda
and sometimes they feel like i mean
we've had it where
um our guides actually just wanted us to
put money into and
do work in their village only because
they just want it you know want to
help their village and their people so i
think you always have to be
aware and even just ask some ask someone
out right like okay
you're our guide this is what we want to
do i mean what's your agenda what's your
wine wanting to help us
we're very direct yeah very direct yeah
yeah
yeah you said that's the question and
you know if you if you both
know if they put on the table well they
i don't know they wouldn't say would
they
but you just kind of have to be really
smart relationships yeah relationships
also as well like there's usually in in
a lot of these villages like when we
first went to zambia
we went to the chief of the village um
who's very important man not easy to get
a meeting with him and we just said look
you know
man is from zimbabwe i'm from england we
have been to zambia a few times i've
spent a month here
this is what we want to do we want to
build boreholes across here here and
here
however we want to speak to you to make
sure that it's done properly we want to
put together a community that can look
after it once it's built
what would you advise and he was like oh
that's amazing god bless you and then he
helped us and
yeah rather than just doing it and not
people not being aware not getting the
green light we went to the zambian
embassy
we spoke about what we're doing we had
the green light yeah now in uganda what
we're doing with the building schools
and stuff we've partnered with uganda
government although we can't go it's so
annoying because the flights
is i'm not comfortable with giving money
unless i'm there
yeah i think it's very important to be
there and to see what's happening
also from an investment point of view as
well there's a lot of
money to be made in um in in
zambia in uganda and i think zimbabwe as
well i thought you always say this oh
yeah oh man i'm to keep that quiet for
the time being so funny though because
people
you know i get a lot of them i get a bad
reputation for investing in the north of
england because people go oh
the northerners you're taking the
properties of them imagine how much bad
rep i'd get if i talked about some of
the opportunities in
zimbabwe people will be furious but
they're stupid because actually
by investing in an area you're boosting
the area people
people really need to start to think
yeah you know people really need to
start to think
so if this video if all it can do is get
you to start thinking um
about business economics giving charity
being intelligent
and and i really think that you know god
will bless you
whether you believe in god or not you
will be blessed when you are
generous when you bless other people you
reap what you sow
and um there's also nothing more
rewarding that than giving
generally speaking give intelligently
but sometimes if you're prompted we've
done some ridiculous giving as well
we've done things that are um probably
not intelligent but we just feel
prompted yeah so um
that's it for today if you've got any
questions again
comment below in the video we'll do our
best to answer next week also
how will people find out about our
charity our organization
we don't ever push people to give you
can you can donate to our
um foundation we don't push that at all
we get
very little donations we've probably had
about 10 people
ever that i've donated um we we fund
most of the works ourselves through the
foundation but if people if someone did
want to get in touch with the foundation
and they did want to give or they wanted
to see how we could link up what would
be the best way to get in touch
if you visit
www.samuelleadsfoundation.org
i'll put a link down in the description
you can click through to there you can
see
all about what we do and if you'd like
to donate as well i'm sure there's a
donate button on the website somewhere
so
cool and also don't forget if you want
to help others the best way you can help
others is by helping yourself first
you know when you succeed in business in
property not only
when you make money in property are you
adding a product of providing
accommodation
also you're inspiring others showing
what can be possible and then with the
profits you can give
and have a snowball effect um so and
that's something i used to grapple with
i still think oh if i want to give him a
generous and
you know i didn't feel comfortable
making lots of money myself but actually
i realized how flawed that was money is
meant to go around
be a river don't be a pond let money
flow through you
uh make money give money make money give
money let it flow through you
um find the words of wisdom final words
of wisdom
no one has ever become poor by giving so
i think we're all blessed to be a
blessing if you're fortunate enough to
be in a position that you
have the funds or the time to give to
others and help others then i think you
should definitely do that
i'm going to be really i'm going to be
really out there right now though and
i'm going to say
even if you haven't got the funds to
give even if you're broke
still give put a percentage of your
money even if it's just like
one percent five percent ten percent and
give and what you'll find is
because sometimes people think oh i i'll
give what's left over
you know i'll i'll live and then i'll
give what's left over actually i think
it's really important to give first
because when you give off the top when
you give off the first fruit
so you get your wage 2000 pounds and you
think oh man
let me just pay my bills and everything
and then i'll give what's left let me
tell you something nothing will be left
you're better off to say i'm going to
give 200 pounds or even 100 pounds off
the top
and then somehow miraculously you can
live and that's why amanda what you said
is so important about no one ever became
poor by giving
so on that note i hope you enjoyed this
video and
let us know if you agree with what we're
saying or if you don't agree if you
disagree you have questions
comment comment comment below we want to
know what you think have a wonderful
wonderful week
and we'll see you guys next time
[Applause]